einfahrt in das bergwerk von annaberg
buchholz mit dem zug geht es unter tage
in einen stillgelegten stollen
die weihnachtsfeiern folge einer alten
bergmanns tradition der sogenannten
mettenschicht die mitte war die letzte
schicht vor heiligabend nach dieser
saßen die bergleute zusammen und
feierten heute eine touristenattraktion
zur traditionspflege gehört auch das
singen der bergmanns hymne glück auf der
steiger kommt es gibt linsensuppe ein
traditionelles bergmanns essen
viele der mitarbeiter im
besucherbergwerk haben selbst noch nach
erz gegraben erinnern sich an
beschwerliche winter da hat man die
leistung auch hinter den fenstern katzen
gestellt diese katzen durch und durch
die scheiben durch und die haben den
dritten den weg gewesen
diesen sommer hat sich das alles
entwickelt diese ganze beleuchtung
weihnachts berichten
es ist eine tradition von uns
bis heute leuchten im erzgebirge in der
vorweihnachtszeit schwibbögen in den
fenstern auch in freiberg der ältesten
bergbaustadt der region im zwölften
jahrhundert wurde hier silbererz
entdeckt das den reichtum der stadt und
des landes begründete
die landschaft im erzgebirge ist geprägt
von kleinen städten und davon
eines der bekanntesten ist seifen nahe
der tschechischen grenze
hier werden holzspielwaren und
traditioneller weihnachtsschmuck in
kleinen handwerksbetrieben gefertigt
besucher können den handwerkern zu sehen
wie sie reucher männlein oder
nussknacker herstellen
made in seiffen ist heute als gütesiegel
weltweit bekannt
an den adventswochenenden strömen bis zu
30.000 menschen in den kleinen ort
holzfiguren wie diese gibt es seit knapp
100 jahren hat diese sache einfach so
was ich schön sind wo wir es jetzt auch
gesehen haben wir die gefertigt werden
denn was uns erst zu schätzen
holzspielwaren prägen auch das bild auf
den weihnachtsmärkten
jeder ort im erzgebirge hat einen
eigenen den ältesten findet man in
schwarzenberg seit 475 jahren
er erstreckt sich über die gesamte
innenstadt bis in den schlosshof
den traditionellen höhepunkt vor
weihnachten bilden die bergparade wie
das lichterfest in schneeberg
vor mehreren tausend besuchern
präsentieren sich bergmanns vereine aus
der region in ihren uniformen 50 50
jahre lichterfest oder so einfach die
die freude oder das zeichen dass der
bergmann das licht geerbt licht bedeutet
leben
es gehörte neben der spitzhacke zur
ausrüstung eines jeden bergmanns sondern
ist dass die alte bergmann tradition
noch so lebendig ist
obwohl keine große abwanderung der
jungen bevölkerung in dieser region gibt
es selber schön zu sehen dass das eine
gewisse kultur noch erhalten bleibt und
auch so viele zuschauer jedes jahr
wieder anzieht
weihnachten und tradition sind im
erzgebirge untrennbar miteinander
verbunden